[Music]
two years ago on her birthday a friend
shared something I will never forget for
her privacy I'll call her Emma Emma
shared I'm incredibly blessed and
thankful to evade it to 30 years old I
don't know much about my kidney donor
except for his cause of death and that
he and I were the same age 29 no one
prepares you for the rollercoaster of
emotions a pure excitement and guilt you
feel when we're saving an organ donation
today on my birthday
all I can do is pray for him I promise I
will never forget what a gift you have
given me organ donation is a tough topic
not only is it immensely personal but we
have to talk about death something very
few of us like to think about let alone
discuss but we need to have more of
these conversations the more we can
discuss death an organ donation the more
likely we are to register as donors and
it's imperative that we have more donors
over a hundred and fifteen thousand
people in America are on transplant wait
lists it is not a fun place to be your
health is deteriorating while you're
hoping for a donated organ every time
the phone rings there's a rush of
adrenaline is there finally an organ for
me for thousands time runs out before
that phone call comes what's shocking is
that the likelihood of getting that
phone call and receiving an organ
transplant vary significantly by region
organs are viable outside of the body
for only a short window of time so the
organ donation network is set up
regionally when an organ becomes
available it's offered to the person at
the top of the waitlist in that region
this means people who live in areas with
lots of donors have a much
a chance at a new life than those who
live in areas with few donors here in
California we have some of the best
hospitals in the world but it is not the
best place if you need an organ
transplant waitlist are some of the
longest in the country this is why Steve
Jobs got his liver transplant in
Tennessee at the time the wait list for
a liver in Tennessee was under six
months while the national average was
over a year and some areas had wait
lists over three years people are
allowed to relocate to capitalize on
shorter wait lists but very few people
have the resources time or health to do
so the vast majority are on the wait
list at the transplant center closest to
them in California and across the
country we simply don't have enough
organs to meet the demand less than 54
percent of US residents here in
California are registered as donors this
is below the national average and well
below regions like Montana and Alaska
where over 80 percent of the population
is registered underlying these
geographical differences are differences
by race and recency of immigration
minorities and people who have emigrated
recently tend to donate less frequently
so populations like California that are
more heterogeneous tend to have lower
donation rates this is particularly
concerning because to get a transplant
you not only to get to the top of the
waitlist but you have to match with the
donated organ based on blood type tissue
biomarkers and size many of these
characteristics are correlated to race
so matches are much more likely to be
found within our own respective ethnic
and racial groups our geographic and
racial communities need us by being an
organ donor we have the opportunity to
go on and save up to 8p
lives these people might be a burn
victim who needs a skin transplant a
neighbor with type 1 diabetes who needs
a kidney or pancreas or a classmate with
a severe viral infection who needs a new
heart one act of generosity can go a
very long way as you consider being a
donor I'd encourage you to have two
conversations one with yourself and one
with your loved ones the conversation
with yourself make sure your questions
are answered being an organ donor is an
amazing opportunity but it can be
unnerving and for many of us the first
time we consider being an organ donor is
at the DMV of all places
who feels introspective and charitable
after waiting in line for two hours when
I was first rung the question of being
an organ donor at the DMV
I checked the box No
at 17 I couldn't shake that doctors
wouldn't work as hard to save me if they
knew my organs could be used elsewhere I
had yet to get the reassurance that the
priority of the health care system is to
save our lives where there were donors
or not and that the doctors treating us
don't even have access to the donor
registry that's all managed by an
external nonprofit my situation was
probably not unique we need to have
these conversations with ourselves on
our own time when we can get the
reassurances we need we can then go and
register at the DMV or online at organ
donor gov I'm guessing many of you are
wondering why add this personal
conversation now I'm young and don't
plan to die anytime soon I surely hope
that's the case for all of us in the
room but I'd argue that it's a lot
easier to think about mortality now when
it feels a long way off and to get
comfort
with our decisions being young gave me
the opportunity to reconsider my initial
no and as of last year makes me a proud
yes the second conversation is probably
the tougher one the conversation with
our significant others and families if
we're ever in a situation where our
organs can be donated
we'll be dying and our families will be
having one of the toughest days of their
lives we can make this a little bit
easier on them by clarifying our desires
in advance this is incredibly important
hundreds of registered donors don't get
the opportunity to donate their organs
because their families insist otherwise
at the hospital we need to prepare them
to make the decisions we want similarly
let's ask them what they want for
themselves let's ask them what questions
they have and help them answer them and
make sure we are prepared to facilitate
their wishes if needed I find organ
donation one of the most humbling and
inspiring statements of human kindness
one person giving the gift of life to
others like Emma I hope that we all have
long and healthy lives
but unpredictable situations happen have
the conversation with yourself have the
conversation with your loved ones and
let's step up and be there for our
communities thank you
[Applause]
you